WANT TO SAY WELCOME BACK TO
COMMITTEE WHETHER YOU ARE
PARTICIPATING WITH TODAY HERE
IN THE ROOM ON THE PHONE OR- IN
THIS. THE ROOM WE CAN'T SAY HOW
WE ARE BACK WITH US AND WE HOPE
YOUR FAMILY SAFE AND HEALTHY.
AND WHILE THE- MEMBERS WHO ARE
IN THE DIET. LIKE SO MUCH OF
THE REST OF OUR COMMUNITY.
TOGETHER WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FORWARD SAFELY IN THE TEACHER.
TO ENSURE ALL VOICES ARE HEARD
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
IS FAIRLY. EARLY IN IN A WAY
THAT X. OPENS. THE TIRE. STAFF
TO IN OF. THE DEDICATED AT THIS
CA. BEFORE WE GET INTO THIS
AFTERNOON'S HEARING WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IS ON
THE SAME PAGE AND HOW TODAY'S
HEARING WILL. OUT AGAIN. TODAY
FOR MORE WON'T LOOK LIKE THE
NORMAL WE HAD TWO MONTHS AGO
THAT SAID WE ADAPT AND WE WORK
BETTER- TO ENSURE YOUR SUCCESS.
IT STARTED OUT. MISSION HOW.
THREE ONE THE PUBLIC IS WELCOME
THIS TODAY NUMBER ONE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ARE GOING TO BE
IN TWO ROOMS THIS AFTERNOON
RIGHT HERE FORTY TWO OH THREE
AND IN ROOM TWENTY. CAN IN BOTH
HERE COMES IN TEN RIGHT HERE
FOR TWO OR THREE AND ON VIDEO
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. HAVING
TWO HEARING ROOMS ALLOWS FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCE SEEN IN FOR
ROBUST PUBLIC TESTING PROCESS.
AND THE THIRD WAY TO
PARTICIPATE WE CAN YOU BE A
PHONE IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE A
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THIS
AFTERNOON WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO PLEASE STOP BILLING NOW.
ONE EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE. THREE SIX. THE ACCESS CODE
IS. NINE THREE SIX EIGHT FIVE
ZERO EIGHT IT IS NOW ON THE
SCREEN PLEASE DIAL IN NOW
WELCOME YOUR PARTICIPATION.
NUMBER IS ALSO LISTED ON THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED THE PUBLIC
COMMENT A MODERATOR IT'S GOING
TO IDENTIFY ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS ON THE PHONE THEY'RE GOING
TO OPEN YOUR LINE IN IT THAT
TIME WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY.
JUST A REMINDER. ANYONE IS ON
THE PHONE PLEASE TO SCREEN
YOU'RE WATCHING. BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT
FEEDBACK- AND OF COURSE IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND CAN YOU ALSO
PLEASE TAKE YOURSELF OFF OF
SPEAKER PHONE PRIOR TO
TESTIMONY TO MINIMIZE ANY
FEEDBACK WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION. FINALLY GET
THE WHITE RIGHT NOW. WORK HARD
TO ENSURE SMOOTH ROLL OUT OF
THE HEARING HEY. JESS NO MAY BE
A FEW BOMB SEARCH GLITCHES THAT
SAID. WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH
TOGETHER WITH SOME PATIENTS IN
UNDER. WE'RE JUST REALLY
GRATEFUL TO BE BACK WITH EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU. ALL RIGHT.
RESERVED ANY QUESTIONS ON
TESTIMONY WILL ROLL OUT TODAY.
TURNING SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD
LIKE TO BETTER DO SOME QUICK.
HOUSEKEEPING THERE ARE FOUR
BILLS HONOR CAN COUNTER TODAY.
ITEMS ONE TWO THREE FIVE
CONSENT CALENDAR ONE TWO THREE
AND FIVE. THERE ARE TOO BIG FOR
ACTION. ITEMS NUMBER FOUR IN
SIX. MONTHS WITHOUT FURTHER ADO
ACTIVATOR DO YOU ARE RIGHT.
THAT MISS LANE CHESTER ISN'T
WITH US TODAY WATCHING ONLINE
MISTER CORNELL CHIEF CAN. FOR
GOVERNMENTS AND FINANCES HERE.
IF YOU'RE GONNA HELP PLEASE
CALL. SENATOR HERE WHERE. WE'RE
LIKE PRINCE SENATOR BELL
SENATOR PASSED HERTZBERG
PRESENT SENATOR D'AMATO SENATOR
TOM PRESENT SENATOR NAY. SO
WIENER THIS YEAR NIELSEN
PRESENT SENATOR WIENER RIGHT
YOU HAVE A QUORUM SO. PLEASE
ENJOY HAVE COMMITTEE OF HAS AS-
SENATOR WILL BE HERE IN JEFF A
FEW MOMENTS. MEMBER WE TO BE
REMOVED FOR ON FIRST ITEM AND
THAT'S ARE CONCERNED COUNTY.
ITEM ONE NINE TWO EIGHT. SB
NINE THIRTY NINE AM FIVE SB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN ARE ALL ON
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR THIS
AFTERNOON IS THERE A- APPROVED
CONSENT. THE MOTION BY THE VICE
CHAIR ANY DISCUSSION. WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY VICE
YOUR MORE LOCK. SERVER NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL ROLE IN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. BETTER
MCGUIRE HI THE REQUIRE HI
SENATOR MORE LOOK I SOON MORE
LUCK SENATOR BILL. SO HERTZBERG
I SENATOR HERTZBERG HI SENATOR
TACO. SENATOR TARO CENTER.
CENTER I SENATOR WIENER. CENTER
HI YOU HAVE SIX FOR THAT ENJOY
ACE ZERO VOTE THE CONSENT WE'RE
TO KEEP THE CONSENT OPEN SO
THAT BELL WILL BE ABLE TO ADD
ON. THAT IS A GENTLEMAN- ON
BEHALF OF THE MAJORITY LEADER
MYSELF AND OF COURSE THE VICE
CHAIR WE'D LIKE TO BE TO TAKE
SOME PERSONAL PRIVILEGE IT BIG
DAY IN AND YOU ON THE COMMITTEE
I'M A. IN A BIG BIRTHDAY HAPPEN
WHEN YOU TURN THIRTY. FOUR BUT
IT'S A REAL BIG. WHEN YOU TURN
FIFTY YEAR OLD. THE GENTLEMAN.
HIS BIRTHDAY BIRTHDAY TODAY WE
HAVE MISTER SCOTT WIENER HALF.
MISTER VICE CHAIR HAS A
COMPLIMENT GIFT BEHALF OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOU. THERE WE GO
THE ARE HAND SENATE WAY THAT WE
ARE TO PROVIDE. THE GUY THE
CHAIR OF HOW. CENTER WINNER
PLEASE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
WORKING WITH PEOPLE HEY THAT'S
THAT'S RIGHT IT. THE SERVER AT
YOU TODAY. GOING RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT YOU SO MUCH WELL HAVE YOU
BIRTHDAY SIR AND SO TO SEE YOU
AND NOT ON PHONE ANY LONGER SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IT IS AND
GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO THE AT. ITEM PART
OF OUR CAN. AND THAT IS FOR I
DIDN'T SIX. HE'S GOING TO BE
PER A MY BEHALF WE'RE VERY. AT
VICE CHAIR MORE LACKEY GOING TO
RESENT TEEN SB FORTY FORTY ONE
THE UTILITY USER TO. FOCUS ON
RULES AND LOCAL PREPAY. PHONE
TAX. IS MORE LOCK FLORA SIR
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER VICE. THANK YOU
CHAIR FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF A-
YOUR TODAY AS BE FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE. AS WE BECOME ALL TOO
FAMILIAR. WITH THE CURRENT
VIRUS CITIES AND- ARE GOING TO
FACE DISASTROUS BUDGET DEFICITS
IN THE COMING YEARS. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THE STATE TAKES
ACTION TO ENSURE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MAINTAIN EVERY
REVENUE SOURCE AT THEIR
DISPOSAL. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE DOES JUST THAT BY
REMOVING THE SUNSET CLAUSE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO
COLLECT UTILITY USER TAXES.
FROM THE REAL SHOOTING FROM THE
RETAIL SALES ARE PREPAID
WIRELESS TELECOMMUNICATION
PRODUCTS. SUCH AS PHONE
SERVICES YOU CAN PURCHASE WITH
PRE LOADED MINUTES. PRIOR TO
THE PASSAGE OF AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY FOURTEEN.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAD NO WAIT
FOR COLLECTING LOCAL UTILITY
USER TAXES ON PREPAID WIRELESS.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN
ESTABLISHED A COLLECTION
MECHANISM SIMILAR TO SALES TAX
WHERE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION
COLLECTS LOCALLY IMPOSED
UTILITY USER TAXES FROM RETAIL
SALES AND DISTRIBUTES THOSE
REVENUES TO THE CITY OR COUNTY.
WHERE THE PURCHASED TOOK PLACE.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY ONE HUNDRED
AND ONE CITIES AND THREE
COUNTIES WHO COLLECT UTILITY
USER TAXES ON PREPAID WIRELESS.
WHICH I RECEIVEDAPPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW REVENUES SINCE THE PROGRAM
WAS ENACTED. THIS MEASURE ONLY
APPLIES TO LOCALLY IMPOSED
VOTER APPROVED UTILITY USER TAX
IS NOT THE STATE SURCHARGE
PROVISIONS OF AB SEVEN
SEVENTEEN. THAT WERE OVERTURNED
BY THE- WITHOUT SB FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE CITIES AND COUNTIES
EXPERIENCING SHRINKING BUDGETS.
WE'LL HAVE REVENUES REDUCED
EVEN MORE FORCING LOCALS TO
MAKE EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS TO CUT CRITICAL
SERVICES. THIS FORM OF
LOCALIZED TAXATION HAS WORK
EFFECTIVELY FOR MANY YEARS AND
HAS BEEN EASILY AUDIBLE THUS
WARRANTING AN ELIMINATION OF
THE SUNSET PROVISION. TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT I HAVE NICK THIS
ROMO ON BEHALF OF LEADING THE
LEAGUE OF CITY SHOULD MEET THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
STEVE CARLSON ON BEHALF OF
CELLULAR TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. MISTER
CHAIR WANT TO GO AHEAD AND ROLL
THEM. UP FOR ME ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR
SO LAZY GERMAN RECURRING MIND
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO
PARTICIPATE IN TWO DAYS HERE
AND WE WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY
THE PHONE NUMBER. IS ONE.
EIGHTY SIX FOUR THE ACCESS CODE
IS. NINE THREE SIX EIGHT FIVE
ZERO EIGHT IF YOU LIKE TO BE A
TO SPEAK ON SB FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE. PLEASE DIAL NOW. TO THE
WAY WE'RE GONNA WORK IT IS THAT
WE HAVE. THE TOOLS WILL BE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT TODAY
THEY'RE ON THE PHONE NINE.
DADDY MR ROMO IN MISTER CARLSON
THEY WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES
EACH WILL GIVE THEM A THIRTY
SECOND. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
CHECK IN WITH THE MODERATOR.
MISTER MODERATOR WE'D LIKE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE MR ROMO ON THE
LINE FROM THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CITIES AS OUR PRIMARY. OUT
FOR FOURTEEN FORTY ONE MISTER.
THIS ROOM- IS ON THE LINE YEAH
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS FROM A
MISERABLE WE WELCOME YOU. TO
THE COMMITTEE U. S. THREE
MINUTES THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR
AND WE CAN PLEASE RAISE THE
AUDIO IN THE HEARING ROOM
MISTER ROMANO FLOORS YOURS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARMA THANK YOU
FOR THE TOP. TODAY THIS IS
CRITICAL LEGISLATION- THAT MUST
BE APPROVED TO HEAR THAT YOU'RE
SURE THAT. LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THEIR OPERATIONS. ARE
CONTINUE WITHOUT DISRUPTION.
CITY AND YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN ON
THE FRONTLINE OF THE PRIMARY-
WHILE. CRITICAL REVENUES HAVE
ACTUALLY DECLINED. I'M AT NINE
EIGHT. PERCENT HERE. WHAT WE
HAVE LEARNED TO BE TRUE. OR
THAT THE VIRUS AND I CANNOT
BACK. IT'S NOT JUST BY SIDE OR
LOCATION. ALL CAL WE HAVE A LOT
TO THE TUNE ALTHOUGH SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS COST THE STATE
NATALIE KNOW ABOUT TODAY. SB
FORTY FORTY ONE CITY ARE SIR G.
FILING SUCH ANSWER ANY TIME I
WE ACTUALLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I THANK YOU TO THE THAT YOU'RE
THIS TO. FOR YOU CAN YOU
LEADERS AND MENTOR TO ME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THAT IS A FIRST
PRIMARY WITNESS ON. FORTY ONE.
WE HAVE A SECOND PRIMARY
WITNESS WHO WILL HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND WE'LL GIVE HIM A
THIRTY SECOND PRONG. HIS NAME
IS I'LL SEND. PRISON YOU. OTHER
TELEPHONE. INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
WE LIKE TO BE TO SEE WE HAVE
MISTER CARLSON ON THE LINE MR.
CARLSON NINE. MISTER CARLSON
THE I'M SCROLLS IN YOUR LINE
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CARLSON WE NEED TO COMMITTEE
YOU A THREE MINUTE SIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN
PARTICULAR NEEDS TO CHECK
WORKING ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE WIRELESS.
INCLUDING OUR MEMBERS SPRINT
NOW T. MOBILE VERIZON TRACK
VOTED AT AND T. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THAT THE COMMITTEES
PASSAGE OF. THE FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE. UP WE WERE ON THIS ISSUE
PROBABLY FIVE OR SIX YEARS
BEFORE THE PASSAGE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. A GROUP STAKE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM RETAILERS WIRELESS
CARRIERS- CALIBER TWENTY
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION- IN ORDER TO
COME UP PLAN THAT ALLOW THE
COLLECTION OF THE SAME. REASON
TAX DIRECTLY NINE ONE. USER
TAXES ON THAT. NORMALLY COVERED
WHEN YOU PAY YOUR WIRELESS FELL
OVER THE FORTY STAKES IN THE U.
S. HAVE- ENACTED PREPAID
WIRELESS SO COLLECTION STATUTES
SB. SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS THE
CREATION OF THIS SYSTEM. AT THE
END OF LAST YEAR- AND- WE
NEEDED TO EXTEND THAT ON SAID
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW WITH
EXTENDED UTILITY USER TAX
PORTION OF IT WHICH WAS ALWAYS
IMPORTANT THESE AND COUNTIES
NOW REPORT NUMBERS. FOR THOSE
WE RESPECTFULLY I AGAIN THANK
CHAIR OUT AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS. TO CROSS AND WE
APPRECIATE TESTIMONY THANK YOU
SO MUCH. WE'RE NOT BE CHECKING
IN WITH TWO ROOMS ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TO BETTER DETERMINE IF WE
HAVE ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT
OF THE- WE- GO BACK THE PHONE.
CEDARS ANYONE WHO. IS
TESTIFYING SUPPORT. WE'RE GONNA
START NOW IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE WE'RE THAN ASKING
INDIVIDUAL WOULD LIKE ME TO
SPEAK TO PLEASE RIGHTS AT THIS
MOMENT. IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GIVEN THE LAST IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THE MICROPHONE
TO MY LEFT. HAVING SEEN WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE A GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THIS IS OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY ROOM LET'S SWITCH THE
FEEDER ROAD TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WE'RE GONNA SEE IF ANY
INDIVIDUAL WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL SB
FIFTEEN FORTY ONE. I BURKE WE
HEAR VOICES BUT NO ONE IN
SUPPORT IT'S ALL GOOD WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING BACK TO OUR
PHONE LINES LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE A
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR-OPPOSITION TO THE BILL EIGHT.
FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE
SIX FOUR THE ACCESS CODE IS
NINE THREE SIX. EIGHT FIVE ZERO
EIGHT. ARE NOW GOING TO ASK ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. MISTER MODERATOR. IF YOU
CAN PLEASE PREPARE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE AT THIS TIME. JOHN IF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE LINE AND
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GONNA ASK ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MISTER MODERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE. BUT
WE DO WE HAVE- LOOKS LIKE FIVE
IN THE QUEUE- FIRST WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWENTY ONE LINE TWENTY
ONE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON LINE TWENTY ONE WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE GIVE US YOUR FIRST
AND LAST NAME ORGANIZATION IN
YOUR STANCE ON THE BILL. LINE
IS OPEN LINE TWENTY ONE. ALL
RIGHT MISTER MODERATOR LET'S GOTO OUR NEXT LINE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN FORTY ONE MISTER
MODERATOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
ACTUALLY THE NEXT- WE WILL GO
TO LINE FOURTEEN LINE FOURTEEN
YOUR OPEN. WE WELCOME LINE HERE
MISTER CHAIR. PLEASE GO RIGHT
AHEAD RIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN ANYTHING CAN WITH THE
VISION ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF ME
THESE SERVICES AND TRUNK BEFORE
THE BELL THANK YOU THINKING
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU
PARTICIPATED THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR LET'S OPEN UP
THANKS A LOT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MODERATOR. SIXTEEN ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
LINE SIXTEEN GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE ROCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BURBANK AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ROSS THANK
YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE BRIDGES XIN
IN YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE
GRATEFUL. AS A MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO THE NEXT OPEN LINE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS MISTER MODERATOR.
ALL RIGHT THE NEXT LINE IT WILL
GO TO A WILL BE AT LINE TWENTY
TWO. LINE TWENTY TWO YOU ARE
OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON LINE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CONTROL
HERNANDEZ FROM THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HERNANDEZ THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE GRATEFUL
YOU PARTICIPATED TODAY THANK
YOU MS HERNANDEZ. MISTER
MODERATOR WITH ACTIVITIES SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE. YES NEXT TO GO TO
LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT MONIQUE FIGUEROA ON BEHALF
VERIZON IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
RIGOR FIGUEROA WE'RE GRATEFUL.
MISTER MODERATOR HOW MANY FOLKS
WE HAVE LEFT IN THE QUEUE. TIME
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE
pMODERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT GONNA ASK
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BEFORE FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO BE
PLEASE PREPARE TO SPEAK IN JUST
A MOMENT. MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE PREPARE ANY
DIGITAL WANTING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE NOW. THOSE IN OPPOSITION
WOULD YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU'RE NOT POSITION. OR ASKING
INDIVIDUALS TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION SB
FOURTEEN FORTY ONE. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES HOW MANY
FOLKS DO WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE ONE IN THE
QUEUE SO THE LINE WE'LL GO TO
WE GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON.
KATHLEEN MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
THIS IS MARGARET GLAD SCENE I'M
ACTUALLY SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
BUT I HAD A LITTLE OPERATOR
ERROR ON MY END SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. AND T. MOBILE
THANK YOU FOR CARING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. GLANCING THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE TRULY APPRECIATE
YOU PARTICIPATING TODAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MISTER MODERATOR
WE'D LIKE TO BE A TO DO ONE
LAST CALL LAST CALL FOR EITHER
THOSE WHO WERE OPPOSED OR MAYBE
SOMEONE WHO MAY STILL BE IN
SUPPORT. WE'RE GONNA DO A LAST
CALL ON SB FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
ASKING FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
MISTER MODERATOR HOW MANY IN
THE QUEUE. WE HAVE ONE IN THE
QUEUE- AND THAT WILL BE LINE
TWENTY ONE LINE TWENTY ONE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON. HI
THIS IS JEFF NEAL AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANKS SO MUCH FROM C. SEPARATE
FROM YOUR TESTIMONY. MISTER
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE LEFT
IN THE QUEUE. AT THIS TIME NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. THAT IS
WRAPPED UP OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY
ON SB FOURTEEN FORTY ONE WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO OPEN
UP TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS WILL ALSO
COME A MOTION AT THIS TIME. MR
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR STREAMLINED MOVED TO A
MOVE THE BILL AND SAY THAT I. I
SUPPORTED THIS BEFORE AND I
SUPPORTED NOW IS WE SEE.
TECHNOLOGY CHANGING FIRSTERS A
REASON PEOPLE HAVING HIS
PROPOSED PHONE CARDS THIS IS AN
EQUITABLE AND THOUGHTFUL WAY TO
PROCEED. I SUPPORTED AND THE
WILL OF THE BILL. THE MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. TURNING SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WERE TO TURN OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR FOR ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS MISTER VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF.
PRESENTING YOUR BILL. NICE TO
HAVE A REPUBLICAN TALK ABOUT.
TAXES THANK YOU. BUT COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
INDUSTRY IT'S A CLOSING A
UNIQUE LOOPHOLE AND IT'S A
LOCAL TAX THAT MAYBE ONE OUT OF
EVERY FIVE CITIES UTILIZING-
AND IT IS CRITICAL AT THIS
TIME- IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY SO
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
BY SHARE MOTION IS ON THE I THE
PARTY LEADER DO TO A RATIONS
NOW BROKEN PLEASE SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI WIRE HI SENATOR
MORLOCK. WILL SOON LOCK BY
SENATOR BILL. REBEL I SERB
HERTZBERG. SAID HERTZBERG HI
SENATOR D'AMATO. SENATOR TO HI
SENATOR NEAL. SAID NIELSEN HI
SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR WIENER
FIVE SEVEN ZERO THE GENTLEMAN
THAT IS A SEVEN ZERO VOTE WE
THAT BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE WILL CLOSE IN THE ROLE
ON SB FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
MEMBERS ARE NOW GOING TO INVITE
SENATOR BELL TO BE A PERSON SB
NINE FORTY CENTER BILL IF YOU
DON'T MIND YOU CAN STAY RIGHT
WHERE YOU'RE AT OR WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT. AT THE- SEC.
FOCUSING ON THE HOUSING CRISIS
ACTED TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FOCUS ON THE GREAT CITY OF SAN
JOSE CENTRE BELL THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. OUR MEMBERS ARE ENSURE
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE CITY OF SAN JOSE TO
MAKE SMART ZONING UPDATES. AND
PROTECT OUR OPEN SPACE AND
REDUCE FOR ALL- SAN JOSE IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ON AN
AGGRESSIVE PLANT. MONNING
INCREASED INFILL HOUSING AND-
AROUND TRANSIT. AND THESE BILL
THIS- EFFORTS TO COMPLY WITH
SB. THIRTEEN THIRTY THREE SIR
WHAT COUNTS HIS BILL. OF. IT'S
THE WORLD OF WHOLE STATE IS A
PROPERLY FOCUSED ON INCREASING
HOUSING PRODUCTION- WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IT RESPONSIBLY AND
SOUNDS THEY WERE IN THE PROCESS
OF REZONING OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND ACRES OF OPEN SPACES
CURRENTLY INCORRECTLY ZONE FOR
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES THE CITY
WILL USE CITY SCANNERS AND
URBAN CORE YOUR TRIP TO REPLACE
THIS HOUSING PASSAGE. IN ORDER
TO STAY IN COMPLIANCE WITH
OTHER STATE LAWS AND MEET THE
DEADLINES A CITY NEAR THE
AUTHORIZATION TO GET THE WORK.
YOUR THIS AUTHORIZES THE SAN
JOSE CITY TO UP HIS OWN HOUSING
SITES PROACTIVELY AND INCIDENT
DOWNS OWN THESE SITES NOT
SUITABLE FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT THE OTHER WORDS SAN
JOSE WOULD GRESLEY UPS OWN IN
THE URBAN CORE. AND THEN DOWN
ZONE. THE CAPACITY TO
APPROPRIATE ZONE IN THIS OPEN
SPACE AREA AND I WANT TO MAKE
IT CLEAR I CRAFTED THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THERE IS NO NET LOSS
OWNING. AND NO DECREASE IN
HOUSING CAPACITY AND LIKE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE- IS
THIS IS DEDICATED TO BOTH THE
INCREASING HOUSING PRODUCTION
AND THE PRESIDENT PRESERVATION.
OF OPEN SPACE LAND. ARE WE HAVE
THE CITY OF SOUND SPEAKERS AT
THE CORE CAN. OPENS THE DOOR TO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER BELL
THAT'S RIGHT WE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION AND SB NINE
FOUR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THOSE WHO ARE
WATCHING IN IN THE AUDIENCE WE
HAVE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT EACH WITNESS WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES TO BE IN A
TESTIFIED- IT WILL GIVE THEM A
THIRTIES. PROMPT BOTH WITNESSED
ARE ON THE LINE AND WE'RE I
KNOW- TO THE CITY OF SAN JOSE'S
REPRESENTATIVE. MICHAEL BRELO.
YOUR BELOW THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOU HAVE FIFTEEN MINUTES MISTER
MODERATOR TO WE HAVE MICHAEL
BRELO FROM THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
ON THE LINE. MISTER MODERATOR
OR CHECK AN INDISCRIMINATE. GO
AHEAD MR MODERATOR. THIS IS
MICHAEL CAN YOU HEAR ME OK MR
BRELO WE WELCOME YOU SIR YES WE
YOUR IN COMMITTEE WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN A THREE MINUTE SIR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS ON. THE NINE FORTY.
GREAT THANK YOU OKAY SO MIKE MY
NAME IS MICHAEL BRIO I MIGHT
GET YOU DIRECTOR AND IF YOU CAN
OF THE APARTMENT OF PLANNING
BUILDING AND CODING FIRST FOR
CODE ENFORCEMENT. FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR BELL FOR
ALL. OFFERING THE BILL I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
GOVERNMENT FINANCE COMMITTEE.
STATUS IN VERY HELPFUL IN THE
THING THIS BILL FORWARD. IN
ADDITION I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR SKINNER'S OFFICE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE STATE TO
DENNIS BY STRATEGY STRATEGIES
TO RESOLVE THE TECHNICAL CHECK.
IS GREAT SB THREE THREE. THREE
THREE. THIS IS GONNA THEY HAVE
ELEVEN TO ACRES OF LAND
DESIGNATED EXTRA PLAN FOR A
GROUP IN OAK RIDGE. WHEN IN
CANADA PRESERVED AGRICULTURAL
YOU NATIVE PLANTS AND ANIMALS
AND IF NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S TO MAKE RESILIENT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. THIS LAND OWNED
PERCENT FAMILY HOME THANKS TO
THE LEGACY OF SITTING DOUG
HAMMER WHOSE- THESE OUTLYING
RURAL AREAS I JUST STEP TO
IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENT HIS VISION
AND MAKING SAN JOSE. BRAWLING
SUBURBAN CITY. BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SAN JOSE FIFTY
SMART GROWTH STRATEGY
ULTIMATELY PUBLISHING GROUP
FOUNDRY SHIP GROWTH INTO UNTIL
AREAS. CURRENTLY THIS
UNDERGOING. ACHING THAT'S THE
PLAN TO END IN. CITIES CLOSE TO
TRANSIT IN PART TO ADDRESS
CURRENT CRISIS. AT THE SAME
TIME HE'S TAKING STEPS TO
FURTHER PRESERVE OUR
AGRICULTURAL AND OPEN SPACE
OUTSIDE OF THE GROWTH BOUNDARY.
WE SELL STATE CHANGES AT THE
RIVER. ACTED FOR THE EXTENT OF
THE- LANCE I'M GONNA. SENATE
BILL NINE WITH AUTHORIZED
CANADA UPS ON HOUSING SO CRACK.
UP TO A YEAR DOWN DOWNS ON SITE
SUCH AS THOSE AND COYOTE VALLEY
AND ARE HELD. TO ENSURE NO NAY
LOSS IN RATHER CAPACITY THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT CITY CAN OUR-
SO OKAY HOW DEVELOPMENT
CONSISTENT WITH PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING OPEN SPACE IN
AGRICULTURAL LANDS. OF THE JUST
WHAT YOUR SUPPORT SB NINE FORTY
THIS YEAR TO ALLOW THE CITY OF
FLEXIBILITY FOR ADDITION.
ANYONE WITH. TO PRESERVE ALL
AND- YOUR CALL AND OPENS NEXT
PLAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TESTING AND I
POWER ABOUT BUT YOU'RE IN YOUR
NAME YOU CAN'T IN THE MASK ON
ME BETWEEN YOUR NAMES COLLEGE
AYE SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER BRIO.
PLEASE COME IN. IN THE- WE ARE
GOING TO BE AT HEARING FROM
MARKET LANDGRAF. REPRESENTING
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY OPEN
SPACES SORTIE I LIKE TO ASK MR
MODERATOR IS MISTER LANDGRAF IN
THE QUEUE AND READY TO PREPARE
READY FOR HIS TESTIMONY. SIR
MISTER LANG RAPID ON. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU GOOD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARK LAND ROUGH WITH THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE OF
FORTY CO SPONSOR SB NINE. I
FIRST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
AGENCIES CREDIT DUE TO CENTER
SKINNER WHOSE SB THREE THIRTY
SIGNED INTO LAW LAST YEAR. HOW
TO DRESS THE SEVERE HAPPENING
CRISIS WE FACE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE ALL IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THOSE EFFORTS. WE ALSO FULLY
SUPPORT INITIATIVE THAT. LAYS
EFFORTS TO BUILD MORE HOUSING
BUT I ALSO WORK TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE. SB NINE FORTY
DE COUPLING I'M UP SPINNING AND
DOWNS ON IT. BY ALLOWING UP
SOON. I THINK THAT. IN THE
URBAN OR TO OCCUR FOR. THE BANK
AND THEN LATER USED DOWNS AND
HOW EVER. AREAS THAT ALLOWS
OWNING TO. WITH THE EXIT
GENERAL PLAN DESIGNATION.
ALLOWS THE CITY TO REDUCE
SPRAWL AND PROTECT ITS VITAL
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS BOB
PRIORITIZING HOUSING. SPRAWL
NOT ONLY INCREASES VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED AND THEREFORE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. YOU
CAN ALSO IN THE NATURAL
STRUCTURE ON WHICH IT INSTEAD.
REDUCE FLY. MAJORS TO REDUCE
FIVE TO RECHARGE. AND TO
SUPPORT A LOCAL BRAZILIAN FOOD
SUPPLY. ALL ALSO PUTS MORE
HOMES AND ORGANS IN THE WILD
LAND URBAN INTERFACE THAT'S
INCREASING EXPOSURE RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES TO WILD ARE. WE ARE
THEREFORE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CITY'S EFFORTS TO TAKE A
SMART GROWTH APPROACH AND
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE SPRAWL
INCLUDING AN KILEY BALLET AS
MICHAEL MENTIONED ABOUT CAN OF
WHICH LIES WITHIN THE CITY
LIMITS SAN JOSE AND ALL OF
WHICH HAS BEEN DESIGNATED.
SCAPE OF STATEWIDE IMPORTANCE
EIGHTY NINE FORTY EIGHT CO
AUTHORED BY SENATOR BELL LAST
YEAR WHICH HAD BEEN SIGNED INTO
LAW. IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO CENTER BELL IN THE
STAFF FOR THEIR EFFORTS. TO
ALTER THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. RESPECTFULLY
QUESTION I VOTE SB NINE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY MICHELIN GRAFT WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT WILL CONCLUDE OUR
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES FOR. ALL
ISSUES OF SB NINE FORTY WE ARE
NOW GOING TO GO IN TWO OR THREE
PHASE PUBLIC TESTIMONY PROCESS
FOR SB NINE FORTY. WE'RE GONNA
START FIRST WITH ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AND SUPPORT.
SB NINE FORTY HERE IN ROOM FOR
TWO OR THREE TO GET PLEASE COME
TO THE MICROPHONE TO MY LEFT.
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST
NAME ALONG WITH YOUR
ORGANIZATION. WE WELCOME ANYONE
AT THIS TIME. SEEN KNOWN COME
FORWARD WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO OUR REMOTE TESTIMONY ROOM
THAT'S ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE VIDEO AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. ACTIVITIES TEST
IN SUPPORT SB NINE FORTY. LAST
CALL IN ROOM TWENTY FOURTEEN IN
SUPPORT. ERIN HEARING AND
SEEING NO ONE COME FORWARD TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR PHONE
LINES WE'RE GONNA ASK THE
MODERATOR DO PLEASE PREPARE ALL
INDIVIDUALS ON THE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO SPEAK IN OF
NINE FOUR THE MODERATOR PLEASE
FOR. THE NINE. IN GERMAN AND
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW. MISTER MODERATOR
LET'S OPEN AT THE LINES TO GO
TO THE FIRST PERSON SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FORTY.
ABSOLUTELY WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q.
SO THE LINE THAT WE WILL GO TO
HIS LINE TWENTY FIVE LINE
TWENTY FIVE YOU ARE. GOOD
AFTERNOON ALL RIGHT FOR HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
WE'RE GRATEFUL. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE MISTER MODERATOR IN THE
QUEUE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FORTY. AT THIS TIME IS NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
MISTER MODERATOR WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO. ROUND ROBIN AND
CHECK IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO IS
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
I WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FORTY WE
ASK YOU TO PLEASE STAND AT THIS
TIME. FIRST AND LAST NAME IN
ORGANIZATION MICROPHONE TO THE
LEFT OPPOSITION NINE FORTY.
KAREN SEEN NINE WE NOW WOULD
LIKE TO BE A TO GO TO A REMOTE
HEARING ROOM. ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WE LIKE TO BE A TO OPEN IT UP
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO SB NINE
FORTY PLEASE COME FORWARD NOW.
WE'RE GOING TO ALASKA ALL IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSITION.
OF SB NINE FORTY. HEARING SEEN
NINE DAYS IN JENIN THE
COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO
BACK TO OUR PHONE LINES WE'RE
GONNA ASK INDIVIDUALS DIAL.
844-291-6364 BUT THE ACCESS
CODE OF NINE THREE SIX EIGHT
FIVE ZERO EIGHT IF YOU'D LIKE
TO BE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE FORTY. MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE PREPARE ANY
INDIVIDUAL ON THE LINE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FORTY
AT THIS TIME. AND CLEAN
GERMANOPHILE MIND IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FORTY. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO ARE ON THE PHONE OPPOSITION
OF NOT. SB NINE FORTY LAST CALL
MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FORTY. AT
THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE. WE'RE GOING TO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR ALL YOUR WORK
TODAY MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE A TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OR IN ONE DAY TO BE TO OFFER A
MOTION WE OF THE VICE CHAIR
FIRST AND THEN SENATOR WIENER
MISTER VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THIS. FOR LIKE A-
TO HAVE A- NO BETTER NO WORSE.
POLICIES SO I'M JUST. CURIOUS
WHY WERE CARVING OUT. ONE PART
OF THE STATE WINNER FIFTY SEVEN
OTHERCOUNTIES IN. OTHER AREAS
INSIDE. I'M WONDERING WHY ARE
WE JUST DOING THIS FOR EVERY
ONE. THIS RUDY WILL WILL THIS
JUST KIND OF GENERATED- A
PLETHORA OF BILLS EVERY YEAR
FROM LOCALITIES AT ONE THE SAME
TREATMENT I JUST. WOULD LIKE TO
JUST HAVE A DISCUSSION ON THAT
SIMPSON REBEL BE IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND HELPING ME OUT.
WELL HAVE A STATE OF EMERGENCY
HERE BECAUSE THE CITY IS ON THE
SCHEDULE TO AMEND THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT. AND WOULD LIKE TO DO
SO- WITH THESE- POLICIES THAT
ARE OUTLINED IN SB NINE FORTY
ON MINE. SO IN ORDER TO DO
THAT. THE CITY OF SAN JOSE- IS
REQUESTING APPROVAL THIS BILL.
THE BILL IS IT A- A WIDESPREAD
SUPPORT FROM THE OPEN SPACE FOR
PARTY. BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. AND OTHERS AND THE
REASON WHY IS BECAUSE- THERE IS
A- LONG STANDING AGREEMENT THAT
THIS AREA SHOULD BE LEFT IN
OPEN SPACE THE- FOR. BACK IN
THE SIXTIES SEXUALLY. SO IT IS.
INAPPROPRIATE NOT BEEN CAN NOT
BEEN- CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE
CITIES GENERAL PLAN FOR SOME
TIME AND NOW IS THE TIME TO DO
THIS SO THAT WE CAN PROCEED
AHEAD WITH- OUR HOUSING ELEMENT.
DO NOT DO SO WOULD DELAY THE
HOUSING AND THE DELAY THE
HOUSING ELEMENT AND NO FOR
LARGE CITY OF ALL OF OVER NOW
OVER A MILLION PEOPLE- DELAY
THE CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO. OUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AT CENTRE BELL A
MISTER BY SHEER A PLEASE. DON'T
FORGET TO SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER LITTLE ODD
TALKING THROUGH MESS BUT WILL
GET USED TO THE NEW TEMPORARY
NORMAL UNTIL WE BEAT THIS
THING- SO I A CALL- I SUPPORT-
THIS BILL. TOM I THINK THIS IS-
TAKING A VERY COMMON SENSE.
APPROACH TO- A SPECIFIC
PROBLEMS JOSE. HIS FACE SAYING-
IN TERMS OF THE RESTRICTIONS
THAT WE PUT ON DOWN ZONING BUT
YOU HAVE A CITY. THAT IS NOT
REALLY LOOKING TO DOWN ZONE
ONCE A GOOD DANCER IN SOME
AREAS WHILE PROTECTING
OUTLYING. AREAS SECONDLY TO
SPRAWL SO I THINK THIS IS A
UNIQUE SITUATION- AND IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE ONE- WE DEAL WITH
SOMETIMES SPECIFIC BILLS
SPECIFIC CITIES AND COUNTIES ON
A REGULAR BASIS WE DO WITH
NAPA. COUNTY AND NOT THE CITY
LAST YEAR ON A VERY SPECIFIC
ISSUE- WHICH IS A VERY PRO
HOUSING BILL BUT REALLOCATED
RINA. BETWEEN THE CITY AND THE
COUNTY IT'S NOT SOMETHING WE
WOULD NORMALLY DO BUT IT MADE
SENSE. IN THAT SPECIFIC
SITUATIONS OF A GOAL ANYA AND-
IS TO ALLOW FOR MORE HOUSING
ZONE FOR MORE HOUSING. TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE FOCUSING
ON HOUSING AND URBANIZED. AREAS
RATHER THAN GOING TO EARN
FURTHER OUT HAVING SPRAWL. THIS
BILL ACCOMPLISHES THAT IT'S A
GOOD BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
A- THE YOU BUT SHE THE CENTER
WE HAVE A MùT. ON THE FLOOR
WE STILL HAVE NUMBER DISCUSSION
ON SB NINE FORTY. RENT TURNED
OVER TO THE GOOD SEND OF THE
DEAN OF THE SENATE MISTER
NIELSEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. IN THE PAST DIVE
OPPOSED SIMILAR BILLS BECAUSE
OF MY CONCERN ABOUT EQUITABLE
TREATMENT TO RURAL COUNTIES.
I'VE COME UP WITH THE-
CATEGORIZATION OF COUNTIES I
COLUMN SUBURBANITES AND COUNTY
SUBURBAN. URBAN RURAL SUBURBAN
ICING SUBRBAN ISING WOULD BE
IT UP COUNTY IN TRANSITION FROM
HAVING BEEN HISTORICALLY
BASICALLY RURAL. AS CONTRA
COSTA WAS AS EVEN THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY HAD HEAVY
AGRICULTURAL BASE AND OVER THE
YEARS THAT DECREASED. WELL MY
ONLY QUESTION- OF NOT A
QUESTION BUT I EQUEST I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL. BUT I WOULD
ASK MY COLLEAGUES FOR MORE
URBAN AREAS WHENEVER WE MAY
HAVE SUCH AN OCCASION TO HELP A
RURAL COUNTY THEN LOOK FAVOR
WITH ON US AS WELL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR ADVOCACY FOR
RURAL CALIFORNIA MR SENATOR
VERY GRATEFUL. PLEASE A CENTER
WINNER CAN I RESPOND TO THE
TIME TO CENTER NIELSEN I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND WHEN WE DID
THE WORK LAST YEAR WITH NAPA
COUNTY NAPA CITY OFFICE IN NAPA
COUNTY A LOT OF THOSE COUNTY IS
ROLE- AND PART OF THE GOAL
THERE. WAS TO REALLY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
BOTH THE RURAL AND URBANIZED-AREAS AND NOT TO COUNTY SO I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
BOTH HOUSING COMMITTEE I COME
IN FINANCE GOOD VERY SENSITIVE
TO WILL CONTINUE TO BE
SENSITIVE TO. THAT'S PERFECT
EXAMPLE I USED TO REPRESENT.
NOT JUST TRANSITIONING SO THIS
IS THE RIVER RIGHT ON POINT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER WINNER THANK YOU SIR
NIELSEN. PLACING JOHN AND
COMMITTEE WE LIKELY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR. HAVEN'T SEEN NINE WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
FROM CENTER WIENER. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE FLOOR. SENATE
BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR DISCUSS ARJUN OUR
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATE MCGUIRE HI REQUIRE
HI SENATE MORLOCK. SENATOR BILL
RIGHT TO REBEL HI SENATORS
BURKE. CENTER HERTZBERG HI
SENATOR D'AMATO. SOONER TADO HI
CENTER. SENDER NIELSEN HI
SENATOR WIENER BY SENATOR
WIENER HI. SIX ZERO PLEASE
ENTER ON THE COMMITTEE THAT IS
A SIX ZERO VOTE ON SB NINE
FORTY THE BILLS OUT WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE VERY GRATEFUL
WE ALL HAVE A- SINCE LEFT AND
THAT'S ADDING CENTER BILL ONTO
THE KITCHEN COUNTER OTHERWISE
ALL MEMBERS HAVE VOTED ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS TO
VOTE ON THE CONSENT COUNTY DIED
CENTER ABOUT WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL TO ALL MEMBERS.
PARTICIPATED TODAY AT THE
CURRENT VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS SIX ZERO MISTER
BALCONY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR SENATOR ALL FIVE. SEVEN
ZERO THE CONCERN IS OUT RECALLS
NO ROLE PLAYS ENGINE WE WANT
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAFETY YOU ALL
OF YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
TODAY A SPECIAL THANKS CALLING
GRINNELL IN THE TIRE GOVERNMENT
GOVERNANCE AND FIVE STEAM FOR
OPERATING BUT CAN BE
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCE. THANK
YOU FOLKS FROM THE L. HELLO
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING MORE
THAN OVER TIME ON COMMITTEE WE
WANNA. TAKE YOU. CHIU ON A
HEARING WILL DIE WE TRULY FREE
IT OF COURSE TO THE SECTOR THE
SENATE IN HER OFFICE FOR ALL
THE WORK AND FOR MEMBER
COMMUNICATION DAN IS HERE AND
WERE SERGEANTS. YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALL THE WORK **** THANK YOU.
THIS IS HERE OF GOVERNANCE AND
FOR COMMITTEE IS NOW AFTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH.